I want to ask you about about your
wedding is it true that you've gotten a
little bit of I don't know if you cause
trouble but it was just sort of like an
online kerfuffle because you said that
at your wedding Ricky Martin and
Victoria Beckham were the drunkest
people at the wedding yeah and they took
exception to that yes no they just
called me they're like Mitch you were
like oh my god it was me it was me I
liked it I look at when you're so drunk
that you can call other people out for
being too drunk and forget that you were
drunk and much drunker than I was the
drunkest person at my wedding
Wow hands down I don't think I got off
the table right
yeah yeah we had an 80s band and so
they're saying every eighty song you
know living on a prayer we're like wow I
jumped off the table ten times into
random people's whatnot ran into
people's arms because I knew everybody
people's arms there was one guy you
didn't know it was the waiter it's the
greatest thing that ever happened to him
I'm just here to read the gas meter wow
I was it was so much my wedding was the
best
Jay you had a good time your wedding
it's so fun yeah you didn't I just was I
had to take care you have to take care
of a library book I didn't I went around
and I was like them like you know Ronald
like well welcome it's good to have you
yes yes just did that with so many
people and then the wedding was over and
my wife was had left with someone else
they're very happy yeah yeah no I
that was the rule of the wedding was
inviting only people part of our love
story and people you don't to babysit my
wedding my day yeah my day sounding like
your son